energy networks transportation and
financial markets are all computer
driven those computers are connected to
separate networks or to the Internet and
that makes industrial nations vulnerable
to cyberattacks hackers can disrupt
financial markets or even shut down the
electricity supply experts say the
danger is high and continues to grow
terror groups like Islamic state could
wreak havoc British finance minister
George Osborne is alarmed and following
the attacks in Paris he wants to take
swift action that includes better
equipping intelligence services to fight
Islamic state ISIL are already using the
internet for hideous propaganda purposes
for radicalization for operational
planning to they have not so far been
able to use it to kill people by
attacking our infrastructure through
cyber attack they do not yet have that
capability but we know they want it and
we know they're doing their best to
build it so when we talk about tackling
ISIL that means tackling their cyber
threat as well as the threat of their
guns and their bombs and their knives
despite increased austerity measures the
British government wants to invest five
billion euros in preventing cyber
attacks intelligence services are set to
hire 1,900 additional staff in the
coming years the international hacking
collective Anonymous has also declared
war on Islamic state the group is
flagging is accounts on Twitter
attacking is websites and handing over
data to US authorities it's an unusual
alliance considering that until now
Anonymous has often battled against
government authorities